bruce willis has starred in some of the
most iconic movies of all time but a
shocking health crisis has ended his
time in hollywood welcome to
entertainment tonight you know bruce is
a beloved action star and a devoted
family man and today it was his family
who revealed his devastating diagnosis
the heartbreaking post today bruce has
been experiencing some health issues and
has been diagnosed with aphasia aphasia
is a condition that results from damage
to the speech areas of the brain
the disease causes a gradual loss of
speech and the ability to understand
language both spoken and written it's
usually the result of a stroke head
injury or brain tumor though the cause
is unclear for bruce there are
treatments for it though so it will be
very important to get a hold of the
speech and language pathologist your
quality of life is greatly affected by
aphasia however with good adaptive
methods and ways to compensate for the
aphasia you can still have a good
quality of life there are certain
medications and certain conditions that
can be used to help facilitate
communication
the last time e.t spoke with bruce was
in 2018 at his celebrity roast at the
time his speech was seemingly slower
what's your favorite memory from that
from die hard
i never really got hurt
yeah
got banged up but
we've seen bruce on the red carpet many
times since then he's always declined to
do interviews the 67 year old action
star is stepping away from acting
according to his family who issued the
statement across all their social media
signed by current wife emma former wife
demi moore and bruce's five daughters
who are quote moving through this as a
strong family unit as bruce always says
live it up and together we plan to do
just that in real life i think that
being a dad is is the most important job
that there is in the world
over his five-decade career bruce has
made over 100 movies grossing more than
8.3 billion dollars but of course you
can't think bruce without thinking die
hard
e.t first met the 31 year old
moonlighting star two years before the
blockbuster that would catapult his
career hold it down up there
trying to get famous
god knows i'm not that
ghoulish like in real life
did i really say that on entertainment
tonight
this is a tan from hawaii
bruce would go on to star in hits like
look who's talking pulp fiction
armageddon and the sixth sense to name a
few i see dead people
but a source tells e.t bruce has
struggled on movie sets over the past
few years while filming american siege
last year we're told he was unable to
remember his lines the same thing
happened in late 2017 on the set of
glass and quote there were concerns he
was having a medical issue you can't
possibly explain everything away bruce's
glass co-star sarah paulson reacted
today saying he was such an incredible
acting partner to me and is the
loveliest most gentle and hilarious man
bruce currently has eight other projects
still to be released we're told his
health started declining most last year
so he made a plan to make a bunch of
movies and do as much as he could
career-wise so that he could retire and
take care of his family
i like acting and i like
i like entertaining people but
it's not my life it's not really what my
life is it's what my job is what i
really am is just a guy who walks around
the planet just like you walk around on
the planet
listen our thoughts and prayers are with
bruce and his family right now